I've been watching real estate shows for
the past 72 hours I've been watching
real estate shows based in LA million
dollar listing selling Sunset and what I
like about these shows they're not about
anything none of the characters are
particularly memorable they all try to
be that's the thing with like these
reality shows they try to be quirky or
different but they're not the only
reason people watch these is it's real
estate porn and they shoot the houses so
beautifully and everything about la is
sun-drenched and gorgeous and then it's
and then when you walk around I like
even some of these nice houses they're
just boxes and dirt that's what a lot of
them are especially when go over to the
Hollywood Hills
they're just concrete boxes that
someone's stuck in a mound of cat litter
and they put little infinity pools
outside and everybody pays ten million
dollars to live there
but it's really when you see it it does
it's not nearly as impressive as this
beautiful seductive style of shooting
where because bad always tells me all we
can't shoot in the middle of the day
because it's too sunny
but somehow the Bravo team has found a
way to like like it's sexual and they
Joe why is that why can we never do it
but they can do it is because their
equipment is better well they have a
$40,000 camera oh yeah so that's that's
what why do you talk like that well how
much you don't talk like that in real
life you're gonna have half a forty
thousand I didn't look like deep and I
listen back I don't think I sound like
that
you never speak the way you're speaking
right now I asked them back guys these
[ __ ] shows they're so vapid and
they're not real like none of the
negotiations are real because the
negotiations are all very like you're at
ten five we got to find a way to get to
13
we got to find a way to get to thirteen
five for a million apart it's too far
which is too far apart we've got to make
a deal work but the real negotiations I
feel like I like listen this is a little
Chinese blood money they can't get this
amount of money out of the country
immediately you're gonna need to [ __ ] it
take a few contingencies on this deal
okay
this guy's on the [ __ ] run he just
poisoned a river they want him for
genocide but he loves infinity pools so
he wants his property but he could be in
the UN Criminal Court soon at The Hague
I mean they want him for torture I mean
literally but he adores this property
he likes the finishes he loves the onyx
table he loves it he's got multiple
exposures he loves it as one of the best
streets in Beverly Hills but you got to
give him some time to get the money out
of the country because he's being
accused of genocide
he's just being accused of genocide but
he adores that he can get three thousand
feet of outdoor living space because
that's a lot to get I explained this to
him I explained this to him while he was
showing off the arm of one of his
political opponents I said will you just
cut the buzzsaw down for a minute and
listen to me you're getting 3,000 feet
of outdoor living space in the hills
this is big no one gets this not for
this price point because that's who's
buying a lot of these properties
it's dictators it's blood money a lot of
this is but that's why the real-estate
show should just be called blood money
it should be called blood money and it
should be about people talking about
that they now have to sell these
high-end properties to third world the
dictators of third world countries
that's what the show should be it should
be blood money you should be like
there's a lot of powerful people in the
world and sometimes they have to leave
their countries after a coup but they
love the sexy Los Angeles Sun so we're
selling them hot properties sure many of
them have been accused credibly of
genocide and poisoning entire
races of people but one thing they love
is a nice view so come on and swatch
blood money they'll be like the only
people that can really afford these hi
no just be a realtor be like a good
looking realtor like hot Manolo Blahnik
shoes she'll be sitting on Sunset
Boulevard and she'll be like you know
some of the only people that can afford
these properties right now are murderers
I mean real murderers I'm not even
talking about OJ I mean they've done
[ __ ] I'm talking about biblical
proportions I mean they have laid down
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
people but they're coming it like
Michael Bloomberg I remember who like
delusional people think is going to be
the president like how nuts do you have
to be to think Bloomberg has a shot or
how rich because that's also I've my
friends parents are very wealthy and
they're like we like Bloomberg
and it's like yeah of course you do um
so how rich or how insane do you have to
be to think Bloomberg is a Bloomberg
said about New York City's like bring
all the billionaires we want them all we
want them all and like you have to
realize as a kid but some of them have
done some dirty deeds you know we want
all of the billionaires so what they've
you know poison people in their own
country they like shrimp cocktail they
like steak let him come here we'll get
him a beautiful penthouse but that's
what it should be called should just be
called blood money you know selling the
Hyatt you know because that's what we're
do we're just selling the rest of New
York in LA to people a lot of them
who've earned their money by grinding
people into a paste so they can have the
kind of money where they can come over
here because they go you know I ground
everyone into a paste everybody's upset
about it but I want my kids to go to NYU
so I want to get some nice and Tribeca
you know my kids love Gossip Girl my
daughter's love Gossip Girl
so I want to get something on the Upper
East Side you
now my daughters are just huge fans of
the hills they love you know they just
they just want to watch it so but that
is literally what I did this show on a
tour bus in New York City where we
rented out a double-decker bus and took
it through New York we would point out
where these like Russian fertilizer
magnets lived and these you know Chinese
amusement park tycoons and you know
Russian gangsters a lot of these people
were gangsters and I don't even mean I'm
not one of these guys who just says oh
if you're a billionaire you're
necessarily a murderer that's not the
worst by the way I mean you'd you would
if you were throwing a dart board did
because there's a lot you know if you
threw a dart board and if you threw
darts at a bunch of billionaires on the
board you would hit a few murderers
pretty quickly but I'm not one of those
guys who's like oh you're necessarily
like an evil guy but a lot of these
people that were just stashing their
money in real estate in New York or LA
were actually really like nefarious
characters that had you know one guy
that lived in the Time Warner Center had
poisoned River in Zambia like he was a
it was a mining magnate I think he was
in heat Agarwal
he was a mining magnate and he had
basically you know he was like you know
somebody who had done some really deadly
things with the waste that his like mine
produced any day they wanted they won
they was like he was literally being
accused of like a genocide or at least
like poisoning River and killing a bunch
of people and then just the idea that
you know he came over to New York and
and and that's why he didn't want this
is why real estate in New York or LA is
so attractive to these people is that
number one they don't buy it under their
own name like nobody gets real estate
under their name they get it under a
shell Corp and a shell Corp is a
corporation that has formed usually for
the expressed purposes of buying real
estate it could be for investing in a
company you could set up a shell covert
to invest in a start-up or something
like that but usually it's a corporation
where you don't have a fit like the
physical addresses therefore
from your address and it's not you know
you have to jump through a lot of Hoops
to find out who the shell Corp is
registered to a lot of these people have
addresses that Cayman Islands or
whatever it's a great way to just move
money around and when you're buying real
estate in places like New York or London
you know half of new construction in
London has gone to foreign nationals
a lot of it in New York has gone to
foreign nationals you know I think at
one point in New York City half of the
real estate market was was foreign
nationals
half of the entire market and it bumped
the condo prices up the average condo
price was like over two million dollars
and you're like well why are all these
people buying all this real estate
because number one's a good asset it's a
hard asset you can live in it you can
rent it out but also it's a great way to
evade taxes this is just a great way to
get to get your money out of your
country it's a good way to get the money
out of the country and hide it and god
only knows where you made it you could
you know could be drugs and narco
trafficking human trafficking
narco-terrorism could be just you know
good old-fashioned you know the the Wild
West of natural gas in Kazakhstan where
god only knows what's happening you know
it's like god only knows where the
money's coming from nobody cares nobody
in the real estate market cares these
people don't care they're not asking
questions I get it there's not asking
questions you look at these people
you're making a lot of money they're
just not asking questions where the
money comes they don't care where the
money comes from they don't care does it
matter does it matter to that someone
sold Epstein that Island
someone sold him that Island there
should be a show where Realtors show
pedophile billionaires Islands you know
and it should be called million dollar
fisting where Trish you know Realtors
like Rosa like it would start like this
you'd be like there's a certain type of
person that loves luxury but even more
than luxury they love privacy these are
some of the top Island brokers in the
world it's not enough to just have an
apartment or a beautiful estate these
people need their own private island
with a private heliport where they can
go and come as they please and take
whoever the hell they want they're
welcome to million dollar fisting
it would just be some chick who's like
you know I was trafficked to one of
these islands as a girl and I realized
that I loved real estate I just had an
eye for it and I understood why the
island was perfect it was just private
it was in the middle of the Virgin
Islands I was just you know in love with
the beaches I I loved that it was just
you know I think it was about 75 acres
and you know it had several places where
we could dock boats it was just it was
just one of those lines so many of the
traffic girls unfortunately you know
went into lives of crime or drugs but I
really just got into the idea of selling
high-end islands to pedophiles so that's
what I do now I know more islands than
anyone else I know the ins and outs were
not and it would just be a you know a
realtor just showing you know showing
somebody around like an island like
little st. James and being like you know
hey how are you guys oh it's good to
meet you how are you hello hi senator
how are you I think you really love
about this island
I was listening everything you told me
and I really started to think about it I
think this is really the perfect
property for you it's very private it
has a heliport right near the house so
there's not a long walk between the
heliport to the house I know that's a
concern for you you know because you
know who knows what state people are
gonna be arriving here in okay you've
got great 360 degree views from your
bedroom so you can walk out on the deck
and see who's coming in from where and
that's super important you know they've
also got a lot of different boat slips
here it's a quick you can make a quick
getaway it's really great and I just
think it's super there's a lot of
underground space which I know it's
super important to you it's super
important to have underground space you
know you could really construct anything
here we're talking about you know four
or five thousand square feet of
underground living space with absolutely
no light coming in it's a very kind of
medieval dungeon feel I just think
that's something that you guys would
really like you know the price is about
it's about thirty million I know it's a
little more than you were looking to
spend but there is some wiggle room this
is zoned currently by Saudi prince but
he wants to get rid of it he's upgrading
his operation right now and so there is
a little wiggle room on price so do you
want maybe are you interested because I
could just call him right now
hi how are you
great listen I have my client right here
he absolutely loves it he adores the
underground dungeon space okay we're
coming in right now at about 20 75 it's
an all-cash deal and we can close in two
weeks I don't know he doesn't love that
number he doesn't love 27:5 I understand
but this is a qualified buyer we're
coming in all cash there's no
contingencies here Oh am i calling
someone just calling one of my friends
think I've lost my mind but that's
really what like that's that's where
we're headed hmm with like a lot of
these real estate shows and I just love
them their hypnotic they hypnotize you
and you just look at and you know
there's these they're all coked out
these [ __ ] realtors is this one
British guzzle look at this house it's a
stunning estate he's so good to have
sunny sight and you could just taste the
chalk as it goes down his [ __ ] throat
it's stunning sight all number one
broker he and Hollywood Hughes